oh good lord I don't think I can have  another baby  [Music]  the last two times you were pregnant you  only show up here when you're pregnant I  know Jessica Simpson addressing rumors  she's expecting another child with  husband Eric Johnson on Mondays The  Ellen DeGeneres Show  very exciting it's very excited I'm not  pregnant on your show are you sure  you're not coming over yet we're  pregnant oh gosh no you're not we got an  IUD is not nothing get it it's gonna get  in that uterus  uh-huh ugh I'm not touching that I have  two beautiful children  yep and not fast that's a fashionista  also opened up about her seven year  marriage seven years seven years and  well coming on seven years yeah Oh  actually no seven it's a long time I  don't know if I've ever had a seven-year  relationship other than with a woman but  no not that cut not you know oh I mean  you know my best days that understand me  but seven years  [Applause]